you need to go to the doctor like you
just have to go and get checked because
much like prostate cancer which my dad
had you should not die of cervical
cancer it's curable and it is detectable
and you just need to go to the doctor
but the reason why the rate is so
alarming with ovarian and cervical
cancer is because it's and you don't
know you have yet so by the time you
know you have it you might be at Stage
four absolutely yeah that's why it's
after this call your doctor I mean I am
so thankful for my oncologist and
everything and he is such a wonderful
good looking man and I'm always so sad
that's how I see him every second
because I do I have to go every six
months now that's my checkup it is
horrible and then you go and they take
your blood pressure and they're like
your blood pressure's up I'm like what
oh crap yeah yeah and then I leave and I
go eat a big fat doughnut and I go
shopping I'm like we you deserve it I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this